Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Es wird viel zurückgetreten diese Woche.
Ja
Also sowohl aktiv als auch passiv.
In der Netzpolitik auch.
Ja, in der Ornitzpolitik auch, aber wir äh wir bleiben noch an Bord äh vorerst, oder?
Bis jetzt genießen wir unser gegenseitiges, vollstes Vertrauen.
Warum auch nicht? Hier ist ja auch äh die vierundfünfzigste Sendung und bevor wir hier nicht dreistellig sind, äh gehen wir nicht von Bord, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was das jetzt wieso beschränken wir uns auf eine Anzahl.
Weiß ich, was uns demnächst aberkannt wird und dann werden wir auch zum äh.
Folge drei, sieben und acht wurden uns schon aberkannt.
Na dann werden wir vielleicht auch zum Rücktritt gezwungen. Das äh ja. Ich freue mich, ich freue mich, was Ratze äh wo Ratze abgeschrieben hat.
Das das war einfach ist da einfach nur lustig oder? Ich meine es gibt nichts egaleres auf der Welt als es der Papst zurücktritt, aber äh.
Ja, bist eine schöne Steilvorlage für witzige Kommentare.
Es ist äh großartig, ja, wie man sieht.
Die wollen wir jetzt hier auch nicht so ungenutzt verstreichen lassen. Na ja, aber wir können uns natürlich auch auf das Wesentliche äh konzentrieren und äh wir haben wieder einen kleinen Themenkatalog äh vorbereitet, so wie es unsere Art ist. Und äh haben,
Uns äh auch einen äh Gast ausgesucht.
Ja und zwar Marco Maas.
Einen schönen guten Tag.
Hör Marco. Ja, äh wir wollten mit dir äh äh sprechen über ein äh Projekt, an dem du beteiligt bist, was unter dem Namen Lobby
Plag läuft und was so vom Klang her auch schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht, als ob da irgendjemand irgendwas aberkannt äh werden sollte.
Es sollten Anerkennung gemacht werden für die schönen Leistungen der Lobby, was die alles geschafft haben.
Genau, wo die Politiker dann einfach nur plagiert haben von äh Lobbygesetzesvorlagen. Ähm du hast das gemacht ähm,
Glaube, du hast, du warst quasi der Leiter dieses Projektes bei Open Data City. Werde ich das.
Genau, ich habe äh unseren Programmierer Sebastian so ein bisschen gestreichelt, äh wann immer er nicht mehr,
konnte und äh habe Richard, der auch mit dran beteiligt war und Max immer versucht, ein bisschen von dem Nerdkram beizubringen, den wir machen, sodass wir alle am Ende irgendwie ein schönes Produkt dann irgendwie rausgehauen haben oder Produkt ist es ja nicht, einen schönen Service, eine schöne Seite rausgehauen haben.
Beschreibt, beschreibt doch mal, was was Lobby-Plug ist.
Also Lobbyplug äh
äh für die Nerds unter unter euren Hörern äh im Endeffekt ein auf äh Gesetzesentwürfe. Ähm was wir da machen ist, dass wir,
Dokumente von von Lobbyisten, die uns zugespielt wurden, vergleichen mit aktuellen Gesetzesentwürfen und sehen, äh wie stark teilweise da Übereinstimmung an der einen oder anderen Stelle sind. Also es ist äh teilweise erschreckend viel, an einigen Stellen nicht ganz so viel, wie an anderen, aber wir zeigen da
ich glaube ich hab wir haben jetzt sechzig Pfund Stellen müsste ich lügen aber ich glaube sechzig Pfundstellen haben wir da jetzt schon drin und es werden noch sehr viel mehr kommen.
In äh eurem Beispiel der EU-Datenschutzreform oder äh generell überall.
Na wir beschränken uns jetzt gerade aufgrund der Aktualität äh auf diese Datenschutzreform, weil da sind äh zehn Tagen ist da eine größere wichtige Abstimmung, wo die Unterausschüsse
ihre Gesetzesentwürfe an den Hauptausschuss geben und darüber abstimmen, ob das alles so in Ordnung ist und so. Und wir haben uns jetzt mal auf dieses monothematische Thema gestürzt, weil's jetzt noch die Chance gibt, äh
da die Abgeordnete dazu zu bringen, sich zu enthalten, dagegen zu stimmen oder sie in die Ecke zu drängen und sie mal zu fragen, warum sie denn wie abgestimmt haben.
EU-Datenschutzreform war ja bei uns auch schon ein Thema, da hatten wir ja sogar schon eine Lobbyistin zu Gast, nämlich die AdWOC-Managerin äh Kirsten
Fiedler, die da ja den massiven äh dem massiven Aktivismus von oder die massive Aktivität von Lobbyisten in diesem Themenbereich äh äh geschildert hat. Äh
man, wenn man den Berichterstatter äh Jan-Philipp Albrecht fragt, der klagt ja auch über eine
noch nie in dieser Form da gewesene Flut an Lobbyismuseinfluss oder Lobbyismus Einflussnahme versuchen auf ihn und und andere,
Ähm jetzt sagst du, sechzig Fälle davon,
konntet ihr nachweisen in Änderungsanträgen oder in tatsächlichen Gesetzesvorlagen oder wie wie muss ich mir das jetzt genau vorstellen, wenn ich.
Nein ähm du hast diese diese Amentments, also es äh,
soweit ich das verstanden habe, wir müssen da vielleicht auch dazu maxims ist unser Jurist der wirklich ganz tief in dem Thema drinkniet, der auch auf das Thema gestoßen hat. Also der war aufgrund dieser Facebook äh versus Europe Geschichte
war häufiger in Brüssel und hat diese Gesetzesentwürfe einerseits gesehen und die Lobbyvorschläge auf der anderen Seite und dem ist aufgefallen, dass da ziemlich viele Sachen wortgleich sind.
Damit ist er dann zu Richard gegangen und Richard und ich haben dann geschnackt, äh was man da machen könnte. Äh deswegen Richard und ähm
Max synthematisch da ein bisschen tiefer drin und inzwischen Sebastian auch, weil der musste aus diesen absolut unstrukturierten Daten etwas machen, was sich so semi-strukturiert jetzt auch darstellen lässt. Äh
ich habe mich da aus der aus der richtig tiefen reingeknieten Inhaltsanalyse noch so ein bisschen rausgehalten, wobei ich da jetzt langsam einsteige, weil wir eben die nächsten,
an Daten haben. Ähm was ich aber weiß ist, wir haben äh Amantments, das sind diese Anmerkungen zu Gesetzen ähm,
die in Unterausschüsse reingegeben werden und dort diskutiert werden,
in diesen Unterausschüssen. Ähm da passiert dann die Lobbyarbeit, dass irgendwelche Lobbyvorschläge reingehen,
in diese Gesetzesentwürfe und dann weitergegeben werden, in die Ausschüsse zum Abstimmen.
Mhm. Wo ja, führ erstmal aus, ne.
Bei uns auf der Seite auf LobbyPlug kann man dann, wenn man,
es irgendwie so mehrere Punkte, die Lobbypropos und die Amandments und wenn man da auf diesen Compereir-Button klickt, äh sieht man für die einzelnen Drafts die äh die die Unterschiede ähm wo Sachen dazugekommen sind, wo Sachen rausgefallen sind. Und kann einer dessen sehen, so
Das war der Lobbyentwurf und das war der Gesetzesentwurf und so sieht's jetzt am Ende aus.
Ja, ich habe da jetzt mal auf das Erste gesprochen, da sieht man tatsächlich ziemlich wörtliche äh Übereinstimmung.
Wie also ähm wie wurden die Dokumente? Ich habe die Dokumente irgendwie dann digitalisiert mit einer OCR oder äh sie hatten schon äh.
Nee, das ist das Schöne an Lobby äh Arbeit, äh die versuchen's ja möglichst einfach für die Abgeordneten zu machen, mit den Daten weiterzuarbeiten, das,
äh sind es meistens ganz einfache Word-Dokumente, die man wunderbar benutzen kann, weil die Gefahr bei einem PDF bestünde ja, dass da irgendwie noch ein Briefkopf mit drauf ist oder sonst irgendwas. Ähm und die Dokumente hat Max eben bekommen.
Verstehe. Das heißt äh ihr macht euch das dann an der Stelle dann auch äh zu Nutze.
Würde ich ja doch vielleicht noch ganz kurz.
Aber wo bekommt ihr denn diese Dokumente her? Also ich meine, die Lobbyisten werden das ja nicht an euch schicken.
Nee, äh also Max ist ja relativ
gut vernetzt äh äh in dieser Brüsselszene und alle, die sich so mit dem Datenkram beschäftigen, Datenschutz und so. Ähm und er hat ein paar Abgeordnete, von denen er Dokumente bekommen hat, ein paar NGOs, von denen er was bekommen hat
und das sind so die Quellen. Und äh vielleicht wenn bei euch irgendwelche Leute zuhören, die auch Zuge auf diese Dokumente haben, gerne an uns schicken.
Kindern gehen in diese Proposis an einzelne Abgeordnete oder an diese Unterausschüsse oder
im Prinzip immer an alle, also kriegt jeder alles oder läuft das eher so, dass diese Lobbydokumente auch wirklich nur von an einzelne,
geschickt werden und man die vielleicht gar nicht zu sehen bekommt.
Das können wir nicht valide sagen, weil wir ja nur im Endeffekt die Lobbypapiere kommen von den Leuten, die äh
uns wohlgesonnen sind. Und meine Vermutung wäre das mutmaßlich auch die richtig schlimmen Sachen und die richtig schlimmen Proposils
eher dann an eine ausgewählte Schar von Leuten geht äh und dass wir jetzt hier wahrscheinlich nur die Spitze des Eisbergs sehen, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Aber jetzt auch schon bei der Analyse von diesem Material, was ihr habt, zeichnet sich schon ab, dass äh das viel Einfluss hat.
Ja und äh um's jetzt vorwegzunehmen, ich weiß nicht, wann wann ihr den Podcast live stellt, aber wir arbeiten gerade an den nächsten Dokumenten und das ist absehbar, dass wir die Zahl der Fundstellen hier deutlich vervielfachen können.
Mhm. Ja, der wird hier zeitnah veröffentlicht, äh in der Regel immer kurz nach der Aufnahme.
Der aktuelle Stand sind äh glaube ich du hattest gerade gesagt sechzig Fundstellen.
Ich glaube aber, dass, ich weiß nicht, wie viel wir jetzt wirklich auf der Seite haben, müssen wir durchziehen. Eins, zwei, sechs, zehn, zwölf, fünfzehn, sechzehn
zwanzig, vierundzwanzig, achtundzwanzig, zweiunddreißig, dreiunddreißig, vierzehn,
Naja es sind mehr als fünfzig, obwohl.
Wir sehen bei Open Data City zählt der Chef noch selbst von Hand.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass du das schneller rauskriegst die Zahl. Ähm die äh wir sehen das Ganze aufgeschlüsselt nach
Denjenigen, die die also quasi nach der Organisation, da haben wir dann sowohl klingende Namen wie Amazon, Ebay, American Chamber of Commerce
European Banking Federation und äh so schöne äh Gruppierungen, dann sehen wir die,
Wir sehen dann die Committy Members, die dann wiederum diese Immens tragen, ne? Und da haben wir auch sehr interessante ähm,
Zahlen dann wiederum quasi wie vieler Plagiate ein Committy Member überführt wurde, der,
Die Person, die da momentan Spitzenreiter ist, ist der Merken Haber, ein äh Brite. Jetzt würde mich nur interessieren, äh die Zahl, die dann hinter dieser Person steht, ähm,
heißt das, dass der,
Dass er nur in einem Ausschuss war, in dem äh Sohns vierzehn Mal oder dass er in verschiedenen Komitees war in den vierzehn Mal plagiert wurde oder wo die quasi auch sein direkter Einfluss dann da ähm.
Nachgewiesen.
Warte mal jetzt da will ich nichts falsches erzählen.
Also hier steht ja, wenn man die Person anklickt, steht hier Amadement Lobby-Content und das ist jetzt seiner Person zugeordnet. Du sagtest ja vorher aber, dass es quasi ja in den Unterausschüssen stattfindet.
Na ja, also es gibt eine Liste dieser Komitees und jeder dieser Abgeordneten äh bringt seine äh eigenen Gedanken eben da rein in diesen äh finalen Draft, der dann zur Abstimmung geht.
Okay, also er war sozusagen derjenige, der diese Änderung ganz konkret dann vorgeschlagen hat. Das
sich dann schon auf eine Person äh reduzieren und nicht etwa nur auf eine Fraktion oder so,
ähm plant ihr denn auch, also ich meine, man hat jetzt hier so ein bisschen eine Übersicht über die Person, was ja auch nochmal sehr interessant wäre, wäre, dass ich das Ganze aufblättern zu lassen aus der Perspektive einer Lobbygruppe, dass man sozusagen sich anzeigen lassen kann
Was hat denn jetzt hier Amazon, Ebay, äh insgesamt auch über mehrere Gesetzesentwürfe hinweg äh beigetragen.
Ich ich hab vor was vor zwei Tagen oder so mit elf auch ein Interview geführt und der Mensch der mich da befragt hatte der kam auf die grandiose Idee, dass man dieses Tool ja auch wunderbar als Erfolgskontrollsystem für die Lobbyarbeiten nehmen könnte, so dass die ihre Bonnie
äh hier anhand dessen überprüfen können, wie viel.
Ah, verstehe.
Vorschlägen dann in den finalen Draft geschafft. Ähm ist natürlich.
Dir das ja gleich mit ausrechnen und dann äh zehn Prozent Abschlag zur Refinanzierung des äh Projektes abziehen.
Das wäre vernünftig, ja.
Noch nicht ganz sicher in welcher Ausbaustufe wir das jetzt irgendwie weitermachen. Also wir sind ein bisschen überrascht gewesen von dem ganzen Erfolg, weil wir eigentlich gedacht haben, na gut, EU Themen, das wird ein Aufreger in irgendeiner gewissen Gruppe, die sich sowieso auch schon mit diesem Facebook Thema zum Beispiel beschäftigt hat, aber
Wir sind jetzt in den letzten Tagen ziemlich überrascht
worden von dem ganzen Erfolg und von den Rückmeldungen und den Medienberichterstattung und so weiter, sodass wir uns jetzt auch gezwungen sehen, aus dem Freizeitprojekt jetzt was Größeres zu machen. Das ist äh für uns auch
interessant gewesen. Das war, ich glaube, das war das erfolgreichste Projekt, was wir je gemacht haben und äh mit den mit den mit den meisten Medienecho. Fand ich hoch interessant.
Na ja, ich meine, ähm man muss sehen, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt, aber das sieht natürlich auf jeden Fall äh nach einem interessanten Ansatz aus, um einfach auch mal diesen gesamten Gesetzesentstehungsprozess äh,
zu machen, weil das,
in meinen Augen eigentlich genau der Bereich ist, in dem eigentlich das Wichtigste passiert, aber der von außen eigentlich am wenigsten wahrgenommen wird. Man hat das ja immer
neue Gesetze werden äh beschlossen und erreichen eigentlich die Medienöffentlichkeit äh unmittelbar kurz bevor es im Bundestag oder welchen Parlament dann auch immer in diesem Fall des EU-Parlament äh durchgewunken wird. Zu dem Zeitpunkt fangen dann alle an, irgendwie auf die Straße zu gehen, aber dann ist es natürlich schon viel zu spät, weil so wie du ja auch schon erklärt hast,
diese Dinge finden im Prinzip in den Unterausschüssen zuerst statt und die eigentliche Beschlusslage wird ja in den Ausschüssen verabschiedet und wenn es aus diesen Ausschüssen durch ist
ist eigentlich, wie man so schön sagt, der Drops bereitet geluscht, nicht wahr?
Und äh wie wie man das jetzt weiter aufbohrt, müssen wir gucken, also
wir haben gerade eine äh Crowdfunding Geschichte gestartet, wo wir mal gucken wollen, dass wir ein bisschen Kohle zusammenkriegen, um diese Plattform wirklich,
jetzt mal ernsthaft aufzubauen, weil bisher ist es ein reines Freizeitprojekt. Die Idee ist am
Donnerstagabend um elf geboren worden und am Sonntag war unser erklärter Zeitpunkt wo wir starten wollten, das heißt wir hatten im Endeffekt,
drei Tage eher weniger, wo wir ähm mit den Daten wirklich arbeiten konnten und diese
so wie es jetzt da steht aufzubauen. Natürlich muss irgendeine Möglichkeit für für User geschaffen werden, selbst Sachen zu hochzuladen, zu markieren, äh Fundstellen zu kennzeichnen, vielleicht drüber zu diskutieren und solche Geschichten. Ähm,
Das haben wir jetzt erstmal nicht gemacht, sondern wir haben gesagt, wir wollen erstmal raus, damit jetzt in den nächsten zwei Wochen noch ein bisschen Medienrummel entstehen kann und Druck auf die Abgeordneten entsteht. Aber dann,
sind natürlich die Fragen, die du gestellt hast, dass man gucken kann, welche Firmen nehmen den massiven Einfluss. Wobei auch das ein bisschen verfälschend ist, weil die ganzen,
großen Firmen sind ja in mehreren Lobbyvereinigungen auch drin und Lobbyieren direkt. Also
Facebook Amazon, äh Google und so werden da die großen Beispiele, die haben eigene Lobbygruppen, sind aber auch zum Beispiel in der Bitcom, sind zum Beispiel in Amerika of Commerce und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, der Druck von denen ist dann nochmal größer als von den Kleinen.
Ja gut, aber dann sieht man ja dann auch eben, was würde von der Bitcom et cetera und von den größeren Gruppen dann wiederum äh gemacht werden und dann
man das ja dann auch wieder schön äh vergleichen mit äh so Einzelbeiträgen, ob das in die gleiche Richtung geht. Also ist sehr interessant. Habt ihr denn noch irgendwelche Lobby
Also habt ihr den sozusagen auch nicht Lobbyisten, die hier äh Eingaben gemacht haben aus der Netz äh politischen Szene vielleicht, auch schon irgendwelche,
Dokumente wieder gefunden.
Wir haben zugespiel
bekommen, sage ich mal. Also äh da gab es eine interessante Geschichte. Es gibt ein Interview auf der Zeit mit dem, wie heißt der Alvaro, das ist ein FDP
geordneter und der hatte uns gleich am ersten Tag so den Vorwurf gemacht, wir seien einseitig und würden 'ne Selektion machen und wenn wir wirklich Transparenz schaffen wollen, müssten wir auch die NGOs mit reinnehmen. Äh interessanter
Fun fact dazu. Richard hatte versucht am Freitag den Menschen dreimal ans Telefon zu kriegen und er hat nachweislich das Telefonat immer verschoben
gesagt und äh also es es kam kein Gespräch zustande. Ja genau.
So und ähm dann hat er uns eben den Vorwurf auf Twitter gemacht, ich habe ihm gesagt, schicke uns, was du hast. Ähm das hat er am nächsten Tag dann auch irgendwann gemacht,
ähm dann hat Max ihn nochmal mit
Spiegel Süddeutsche und ein paar anderen Leuten gesagt, könnten wir auch alle anderen Lobbypapiere haben, die ihnen zugespielt wurden? Darauf hat er bisher noch nicht geantwortet, aber wenn
antwortet, dann nehmen wir die Dokumente natürlich auch mit rein. Wir haben jetzt, äh, ich muss gucken, wie diese Vereinigung heißt, äh, ich will das nicht falsch sagen, Alvaro.
Ähm hier NGO,
Bits of Freedom und von dem Reporte, wir haben da zwei zwei PDF-Dokumente, die jetzt auch noch mit analysiert werden. Also die kommen auch rein, aber äh,
was wir da an diesem, an dieser Stelle nachweisen können, ist deutlich geringer als die Einflüsse durch die.
Das heißt, die NGOs, die schicken noch PDFs und die äh richtigen Lobbygruppen sind schon weiter und machen gut kopierbaren Fließtext.
Also da, das das Problem hatten wir ja durch, das hatten wir ja auch schon mal ähm angesprochen in der in der Sendung mit mit Kirsten, weil
ähm allein zahlenmäßig dieser Unterschied ja einfach auch schon so so riesig ist, ja, dass es da im Prinzip
Eine ernstzunehmende Organisation auf auf europäischer Ebene gibt und dann nochmal ein bisschen nationaler, äh dass da Bits of Freedom jetzt mal auch ein Papier dahin geschickt hat. Äh ist da also tatsächlich im Vergleich mit dem, was ihr jetzt
in einem in einem ersten
in einer ersten äh Untersuchung, mit der ersten Version der Veröffentlichung von Lobby Platt gefunden habt, der da tatsächlich äh vernachlässigt war. Aber natürlich würde mich das auch sehr interessieren, weil das ja auch ein eine ähm,
Zu der vollständigen Transparenz dazu gehört und natürlich auch für den Einzelnen nochmal interessant wär, eben auch den Vergleich zu sehen.
Ja, klar. Ich ich glaube, das wird auch zurückfeuern. Also dieser Vorwurf, wenn wir die dokumente jetzt tatsächlich dann veröffentlichen, dann wirst du ganz klar sehen, äh wie gering das ist. Also Transparenz kann da wirklich nur helfen, um auch diese Geschichte zu entlarven.
Ja, vor allem, finde ich mal ganz interessant zu sehen, welche Teile eines Gesetzes eigentlich in keinem Lobbydokument drin standen.
Ja
Überhaupt irgendetwas gibt, was noch originär von irgendeinem äh Politiker tatsächlich eingebracht wird, was äh nirgendswo abgeschrieben ist. Aber das weiß man dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder nicht, ne.
Genau, also unsere Logik ist auch noch sehr, sehr dumm, sage ich mal, weil wir ja wirklich äh nach Wort
gleichheiten suchen. Das heißt, wenn sich jemand äh wirklich die Mühe macht und Inhaltsgenau dasselbe schreibt, was in dem Lobbyentwurf steht, dann würde es von uns äh erstmal so nicht gefunden werden.
Ja, aber das wäre ja Arbeit, ne.
Äh richtig. Ähm von daher weiß ich auch nicht, ob das so schlimm wäre. Ähm vielleicht noch wichtig, ähm wir arbeiten,
ganz viel mit äh äh dem Palma-Tracker, was auch ein freies Projekt ist, die versuchen auch grade zu Crowdfunden, also.
Kannst du das nochmal sagen, womit?
Tracker heißt das. Ähm das ist ein äh Tracker.
Problem anderer Leute.
Pahltrack EU-Wiki Punkt ORG
versuchen ähm die ganzen Personen in den Ausschüssen, äh die Leute, die Redebeiträge und so weiter und so fort ähm auf einer Seite zu sammeln und haben da auch Maschinenles,
äh Jason Formate zum exportieren und so weiter, so die haben uns da sehr geholfen. Äh die benutzen wir auch als Grundlage, das heißt, wenn irgendjemand sich entscheidet
das mal zu unterstützen, denen gerne auch ein paar Euro zukommen lassen.
Also im Sinne von Freund.
Nee, Pahl, wie Parlament.
Ah okay, jetzt habe ich's äh langsam. Mhm.
Das heißt, da ist ohnehin schon so eine ähm neue Szene unterwegs, äh die sich hier der Datenausgrabung ähm,
der der äh Sofortarchäologie äh Datenarchäologie äh verschrieben hat.
Die sind aber komplett anders, also von daher.
Ja gut, da kann ja noch was passieren, weil ich meine in dem Moment, wo natürlich der Nutzen von sowas äh gesehen wird, denke ich mal, kann sich da auch finanziell einiges ähm,
tun. Ich würde mich auf jeden Fall freuen, wenn wir hier noch so ein paar äh lustige Linien äh irgendwann zu sehen bekommen würde, mal so ein bisschen aufgeschlüsselt bekommen. Ich meine, muss ja jetzt auch sagen, Lobby,
Heißt ja nicht immer, wenn auch viel zu oft, aber nicht unbedingt immer, dass das jetzt was schlechtes ist, weil es ist ja auch vollkommen verständlich, dass von Gesetzesinitiativen Betroffene Gruppen sich äußern sollen,
Ob das nun NGOs sind oder Firmen sind oder so, nicht alles, was jetzt übernommen wird und nicht alles, was äh vorgeschlagen wird, muss ja zwangsläufig gleich aus dem Reich des Bösen importiert worden sein
Aber das einfach mal zu sehen, wo kommt es denn eigentlich her und und wie wie funktioniert denn dieser Prozess, denke ich mal, kann auch dazu beitragen, einfach diesen Politprozess als solchen
besser abzubilden.
Man würde sogar noch darüber hinaus argumentieren, dass Lobby ihn sehr wichtig ist oder mit die,
weil ja quasi in den betroffenen Interessengruppen auch die Expertise für das Feld Licht
Ja, dass sie quasi sagen, also äh um auch zu vermeiden, dass eventuell Gesetze äh vom so formuliert werden, dass sie einen
tatsächlich
eine Branche derart betreffen, dass diese nicht mehr arbeiten kann, weil einfach nicht darüber nachgedacht wurde. Also dafür äh braucht man ja dann auch Lobbyismus, weil wir ja in mit unseren paar hundert oder äh so Parlamentariern nicht die
Weltexpertise abbilden können, so würde man dann argumentieren, ja?
Äh ich meine äh äh es kann ja der Fall sein, dass äh irgendjemand, der jetzt
was weiß ich, kein Studium hat, irgendwie eine normale Ausbildung gemacht hat, sich jetzt plötzlich mit irgendwelchen hochkomplexen Themen für desto eigentlich ein Informatikstudium brauchst, äh beschäftigen musst, wie soll der denn irgendwie auf einer vernünftigen Grundlage entscheiden? Also der braucht ja auch Expertise als Beratung dazu, ganz klar.
Was braucht ihr denn jetzt am dringendsten, außer äh einem? Ihr braucht vor allem Dokumente.
Ja, Dokumente brauchen wir, brauchen wir und viel mehr Zeit, als wir eigentlich haben, aber momentan wollen wir so ein bisschen auf dieser Medienwelle mitschwimmen und äh deswegen sind wir auch relativ schnell rausgegangen mit dieser äh Crowdfunding Geschichte, weil wir gesagt haben,
wann, wenn nicht jetzt, wenn wir jetzt noch eine Woche warten und ein hübsches Hochglanz-Video drehen, wo wir alle unsere Nase mal in die Kamera halten und sagen, hi, ich bin der und der und wir würden gerne das Projekt machen, äh deswegen haben wir das alles sehr basisch gehalten, um einfach mal
jetzt schnell loszulegen.
Ja, finde ich auch richtig. Gerade für in drei Tagen ist das ja echt eine eine tolle Leistung. Wir haben den Link äh äh gefundet, wird einen Lobby-Plug äh ein allgemeines Lobby-Plug bei Krautreporter DE
da habt ihr eine relativ,
würde ich sagen bescheidene Summe angegeben von siebeneinhalbtausend Euro, knapp tausend habt ihr jetzt schon da also denke ich da ist Geld,
gut aufgehoben. Was mir noch wichtig wäre, weil du, du hast jetzt ein paar Namen der Beteiligten genannt,
ehrlich gesagt gerne um der Sache auch gerecht zu sein. Alle nochmal kurz nennen. Da war also der äh Sebastian Vollenhals.
Und zu nun ist jetzt.
Der große der große Held aus dem Maschinenraum, der das Ganze programmiert hat und der als allererstes, glaube ich, auch wirklich verstanden hat, worum's da eigentlich ging. Also äh den kann man nicht genug loben. Und äh der hat zwar ganz komische Tag- und Nachtrhythmen, aber ist echt ein Held.
Ja, also äh denke ich, ist in der Szene auch nicht nicht unbekannt. Ähm.
Dann haben wir den Namen Max Schrémps gehört. Du hattest das kurz erwähnt, dass das der von Europe versus Facebook ist,
der also dem vor, wann war das vor allem in anderthalb Jahren oder was der im Prinzip der Kuh gelungen ist, äh eine Anfrage an Facebook so zu richten, dass sie tatsächlich seine kompletten Daten rausgeben mussten, die sie von ihm hatten.
Ja, der Hintergrund zu der Geschichte vielleicht ganz kurz, ähm es ist so, nach
irischem äh Datenschutzrecht äh ist es so, dass äh und der der Firmensitz von äh von Facebook in Europa ist in Irland, äh hat ein User eines Dienstes die den Anspruch auf äh darauf, dass alle Daten, die über ihn erhoben werden, rausgegeben werden. Und
das hat er dann mal äh gerichtlich auch durchgesetzt. Und hatte dann eintausendzweihundert oder tausendvierhundertseitiges PDF
om, äh wo dann aber wirklich jeder Loginvorgang, jede IP, jede Privatnachricht, jedes Bild, jedes und so weiter und sofort drin verzeichnet war
aber immer noch irgendwelche Teile von Datensätzen fehlten, äh die ja irgendwie über andere Sachen nachweisen konnte. Und da hat er sich dann über lange Zeit mit denen gestritten, äh hat auch Facebook dazu gekriegt, dass die jetzt eine Möglichkeit haben, dass man zumindest basisch seine ganzen Daten auch äh expo
portieren kann aus der Plattform. Also der ist auch unglaublich wichtig für diese ganze äh Datenschutz, Privacy und so weiter Diskussion.
Hatte zwischendurch aber glaube ich auch die äh irische Datenschutzbehörde dazu gebracht, nicht mehr mit ihm reden zu wollen, ne?
Ja, ne, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Also der ist da offensichtlich sehr, sehr aktiv. Ähm dann haben wir noch den äh sich unter Herping Hands, Lorenz Maz hat auch Open Data City und Martin Viertel.
Der also Lorenz äh ist, glaube ich, auch in der zehn Jahre weitestgehend bekannt. Der hat äh kluge Gedanken gegeben und hat äh auch geschaufelt, was so irgendwie so diese äh Datensklavenarbeiten sind. Äh
und denkt jetzt grade sehr gut da darüber nach, wie man das
PR-mäßig, nicht PR-mäßig, aber wie man's so aufbaut, dass man dass das nicht zurückfeuert und dass wir nicht irgendwie mal wieder die nächste Piratendebatte gegen uns haben und so. Also da da
ist er auch sehr, sehr gut dabei darüber nachzudenken. Und Martin äh ist jemand, der hat früher für die Financial Times
Deutschland gearbeitet und war dafür multimediale Produktentwicklung Bla zuständig. Ähm
und den habe ich vor einiger Zeit kennengelernt und wir gucken jetzt mal, ob wir auch mal in Zukunft mehr zusammen machen, bei dem ist toll, der kann sowohl programmieren
als auch äh journalistisch denken und der hat sich zum Beispiel auch über bei in der um die Übersetzung gekümmert,
dass wir jetzt äh Magie haben für mich als, ich sage mal Laien, je nachdem mit welchem Browser du raufkommst, hast du eine deutsche oder eine englische Version, das heißt äh es gibt auch gar keinen Sprachschalter mehr, dass es wieder jetzt zu verdanken. Also Sebastian zu verdanken. Also,
Ganz tolle Leute.
Läuft denn da alles auf Englisch?
Die Dokumente sind alle auf Englisch inzwischen ist die Seite aber ja auch auf Deutsch oder was war deine Frage?
Ja, ich meine jetzt der eigentliche Gesetzesprozess und die ganzen Vorlagen. Also ist das zwangsläufig immer dieselbe Sprache?
Ich glaube, also ähm mir liegen bisher nur Englischdokumente vor. Ich glaube, es gibt da ja diesen Übersetzungsservice äh, dass die
im Nachgang alles in die ganzen Sprachen übersetzen, aber die Dokumente haben wir nicht und ich glaube mal auch so ein Lobbymensch will ja nicht zu viel arbeiten und Englisch versteht da ja jeder, also,
machen Sie es auf besonderen Wunsch, dann für einige wenige ausgewählte Kunden auch mal in der Landessprache, aber ich glaube mal Englisch wird da die Amtssprache sein.
Okay, also die Zeiten, wo äh das französische, die Diplomatie äh dominiert hat, sind vorbei.
Ich finde, müsste man nochmal jemanden fragen, aber soweit ich mich erinnere, dieser ganze Brüssel Straßburg, Kram, da ist äh gibt's auf jeden Fall immer sehr viel Bemühungen, den ganzen Kram da irgendwie auch übersetzt zu haben
Und das äh ist vor allem ja auch keine Scherzangelegenheit, weil das ja dann auch immer nochmal juristisch sicher,
und eindeutig übersetzt werden muss
Das ist äh mitunter äh glaube ich sehr, sehr aufwendig und ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, dass dann nicht unerhebliche Anzahl Menschen gibt in Brüssel oder Straßburg, die mit nichts anderem beschäftigt sind.
Haben wir ja Glück, dass die Briten noch in der EU sind, ne?
Ja, werden wir.
Rausfliegen, dann äh wird jetzt alles irgendwie nur noch auf Griechisch und Spanisch und italienisch vorgestellt.
Also oh, wenn man äh auf diesen Markt umsonst was schaut, äh scheidet es vielleicht gar nicht so toll zu sein. Also im Moment Spitzenreiter bei Lobbyplug, mal sehen, wer ihm da irgendwann nochmal äh das Zepter aus der Hand nimmt.
Es könnte einen Deutschen geben, äh der durchaus noch Aufholpotential hat, sage ich jetzt mal so.
Das wäre aber interessant.
Ja, wir wollen natürlich dann auch eine richtig schöne Ranking äh äh Liste haben sozusagen und den äh Plagiator des Monats.
Ich vermute, dass ihr, dass ihr das nicht ohne Absicht äh gerade erstmal nicht habt, so ein Ranking, ne, weil diesen Aufschrei, den wolltet ihr wahrscheinlich auch vermeiden, ne? Also es ist eher klein gehalten, also so ein Ranking, wer ist denn da jetzt der der
Plagiator oder so findet man da jetzt erstmal nicht, wahrscheinlich wolltet ihr vermeiden, dass ihr irgendwie sofort diesen Aufschrei des Politprangers oder sowas habt.
Ja äh außerdem äh es ist ich habe irgendwo auch gehört, äh dass das Ding jetzt schon EU-feindlich sei, was ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht sehe, also es ist eher im Gegenteil, das kann EU-fördernd sein. Äh ich glaube, wir sollten echt klein anfangen und solche Skandal
Journalist bombast äh Top Ten Listen, die können später kommen und da der Code im Nachhinein ja auch Open Source sein wird, äh kann jeder sich, der so eine Liste programmieren will und
Fähigkeiten dazu hat. Ich glaube, das ist dann das kleinere Projekt. Also momentan ist die Konzentration eher tatsächlich auf die Inhalte und äh Fundstellen zu finden und Möglichkeiten zu finden, wie Leute schneller solche Sachen,
äh finden und erstellen und dokument.
Ja, solange man auch noch kein Gefühl dafür hat, ähm ob man wirklich alle Dokumente überhaupt vorliegen hat, äh verbietet sich natürlich so eine Quantifizierung.
Kommt auch noch hinzu, genau.
Also, spannende Sache. Äh ich hoffe, dass euer Crowdfunding-Projekt da äh noch einiges an Unterstützung euch zukommen lässt
Und äh wir werden das mal dann,
hoffentlich noch sehr viele Lobby-Plagiate oder hoffentlich, ich weiß es ja, wünscht man sich, dass man noch viele findet oder wünscht man sich, dass man nicht viele findet. Kommt drauf an, wie viel wie viel äh Vertrauen man in die Methode hat.
Ich habe gar keinen Zweifel, dass man da viel findet und ich finde das jetzt auch erst mal gar nicht äh so telling, ja, sondern die Frage ist halt eher kann man danach wirklich mal ablesen, wie es zu einem Gesetz gekommen ist. Ja, wie schon gesagt.
Wenn du den Beipackzettel dazu hättest, dass du wie bei bei einem Medikament gucken kannst, äh dieser Teil wurde, was weiß ich, mit dem Einfluss gemacht und der Politiker kann im Nachhinein sagen, ja klar, weil die haben einfach die beste Idee, dann ist das ja völlig in Ordnung.
Genau, da kriegt man immer noch so ein Dinner drei Flyer äh mit dazu, wo dann so ein richtig schönes äh flüssiger Gramm äh mit abgebildet wird, wo genau draufsteht so, dieses Gesetz wurde ihnen präsentiert von.
Puren von Datenschutz enthalten.
Ja, kannst du von Datenschutz erhalten, genau.
Also Marco, vielen Dank.
Jo, gerne.
Wir äh verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle von dir, weil du ja ein gefragter Mensch bist, der jetzt ganz viel telefonieren und koordinieren muss und wünschen dir noch.
Sagt.
Weiterhin viel Erfolg. Ich meine, allein der Anfang dieses Jahres äh ist ja für Open Data City, denke ich, ein äh ein äh sehr feierlicher.
Ja, doch, ich bin auch gespannt, wie die sich das Ganze weiterentwickelt. Mal gucken. Dankeschön. Tschüss.
So, das, das war also das, wir, ich glaube, wir bleiben auch direkt beim beim Lobby-Ing.
In Lobby, es ist super. Das es bleibt heute einfach mal Thema. Und zwar war bei uns ja schon ein bisschen Thema, dass äh ich hab's jetzt,
das Anti-Abmahn-Abzockgesetz genannt, ja?
Wir erinnern uns an die äh an der äh die die Verbraucherschutznovelle, Aus dem Justizministerium, die ähm unter anderem eine Deckelung für ähm,
für Abmahngebühren erreichen sollte, um unseriösen Geschäftspraxen äh vorzubeugen, die also insbesondere im Bereich der Urheberrechtsabmahnungen,
durchaus an der Tagesordnung sind, wo also sehr hohe Abmahnen oder sehr hohe Streitwerte festgesetzt werden und deshalb dann auch sehr hohe Abmahnungsgebühren verlangt werden.
All das wollte ja äh unsere werte Justizministerin verhindern. Wir haben glaube ich der letzte Stand, den wir im Logbuch berichteten, war, dass,
Die CDU sich nun bemüht hat,
Das äh zu diesen Gesetzesvorstoß äh zu verwässern, bevor er denn vom Kabinett äh verabschiedet werden soll. Unter anderem
in innerhalb dieser eine halbjährigen Debatte wurde dann der Gebührendecke von achtzig auf die erwähnten hundertfünfundfünfzig Euro dreißig,
angehoben.
Mhm.
Es gab die Definition der Ausnahmetatbestände,
Da hatten wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Folge, wo wir das behandelt hatten, auch drüber gesprochen, dass es da dieses äh der Punkt war, dass die Deckelung nur beim ersten Mal,
Ähm stattfinden,
sollte, ne. Da hatten wir uns noch die Frage gestellt, ist das jetzt das grundsätzlich erste Mal oder ist es nur das erste Mal zwischen diesem Abmahner und dem Abgemahnten? Es war natürlich nur zwischen dem Abmahner und dem Abgemahnten das erste Mal,
Da wir ja keine zentrale Stelle haben, wo das überhaupt erfasst werden könnte und eine Abmahnung an sich ist ja kein äh irgendwo dokumentierter,
kein offiziell irgendwo dokumentierter Vorgang. Und dann gab es noch diese äh das schleichen des äh gewerblichen,
Ausmaßes. Das heißt, der letzte Stand war, es war schon,
sehr stark abgeschwächt und sollte dann also jetzt am sechsten Februar vom Kabinett verabschiedet werden, denn äh sowohl CDU als auch FDP zeigten sich mit diesem Kompromiss zufrieden,
Und jetzt hat aber der Bernd Neumann von der CDU seines Zeichens Kulturstaatsminister im Kanzleramt,
Ähm und keine Ziele für den Familiennamen. In letzter Minute sein äh Veto eingelegt, ja? Und diesen ganzen Punkt komplett von der Tagesordnung genommen.
Ein Tag später hat er dann auf einer äh.
Also den ganzen Punkt der Deckelung.
Den ganzen Punkt überhaupt über das Gesetz zu sprechen. Der hat das einfach mal so, nee, machen wir nicht.
Weil.
Nee, fällt aus wegen ist nicht und ähm hat dann ähm,
Drei Änderungen nochmal an die Justizministerin geschickt, welche äh er jetzt da also verlangen würde,
und zwar würde er gerne äh die Kostendeckelung ähm.
Also diese Kostendeckung auf die erste Abmahnung für für hundertfünfundfünfzig Euro dreißig. Die würde er gerne äh,
quasi generell haben, sodass quasi wenn du einmal eine Abmahnung bekommen hast im Urheberrechtsbereich, dass die zweite, egal von wem sie dann kommt, nicht nur die zweite von dem gleichen Abmahner,
Ähm entsprechend schon teurer sein wird. So, das heißt, du bist irgendjemand schon mal auffällig geworden, dann fällt die Kostendeckelung weg. Ähm,
Problem bei dieser Sache ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das dem dem Neumann schon mal jemand erklärt hat, weder der Kläger, noch das Gericht können wissen, ob jemand schon mal abgemahnt wurde, weil es eben kein offizieller, kein
dokumentierter Vorgang,
Das heißt, die ganze Vorschlag macht nur Sinn, wenn es jetzt auch noch ein Zentralregister für Urheberrechtsverstoßende gibt, ja. Äh davon spricht er nicht, aber man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen, dass das dann das nächste wäre, was er sich vorstellt.
Hm ja großartig.
Dann wollte er noch weitere Ausnahmen von der Kostendeckelung haben ja? Habe ich da jetzt gar nicht näher spezifiziert gesehen und drittens wollte er die vereinbarte Beweislastumkehr ja? Also es ging ja,
darum, dass ähm die Beweislast auf dem abmahnenden liegen soll, damit man also nicht einfach äh so,
ähm dass der Abend meiner erstmal vernünftige Beweise haben muss, bevor er jemandem eine Abmahnung schickt,
und das nicht an die Beweislast bei dem abgemahnten Licht zu sagen, dass es nicht war. Ja, das sollte also umgekehrt werden,
Ähm und das soll so ein Gegenanspruch der Verbraucher äh installiert werden, sodass diese Beweislastumkehr äh ähm auch quasi wertlos ist und nicht mehr zum Zuge kommt. Ähm.
Ein Tag später stellte der sich dann ähm bei einer Rede
auf dem deutschen Produzententag in Berlin auf die Bühne und sagte, ich konnte erreichen
dass der ursprünglich anvisierte Termin zur Kabinettsbefassung am sechsten Februar zunächst vom Tisch ist, sodass die Chance besteht
Korrekturen vornehmen zu können. Wir wissen natürlich, dass ähm hier wir langsam in einen Bereich kommen,
der ähnlich dem,
dem Leistungsschutzrecht ist, dass also bei noch weiteren längeren Verschiebungen da tatsächlich der Fall eintreten könnte, dass das einfach in dieser Legislaturperiode nichts mehr wird, ne? Und da finde ich natürlich
Kulturstaatsminister vorgeht und ein ein Kompromiss der nach nach sechs Monaten Debatte,
Wurde, einfach nochmal mit seiner, mit seiner, mit seinem persönlichen Veto belegt. Ähm ich wusste erstens gar nicht, dass ein Staatsminister das kann.
Ja, ist mir auch neu, also gib wem gegenüber wurde dieses Veto, also auf welcher Ebene wurde dieses Veto ausgesprochen?
Ne, der hat's offensichtlich einfach von der Tagesordnung gestrichen.
Der Tagesordnung von von welchem.
Von der Kabinettssitzung, bei der man bei der man sich dann äh darauf geeinigt hätte.
Ähm diesen Vorschlag zu übernehmen und oder diesen Gesetzesvorschlag dann zu verabschieden und äh hinabzureichen ins Parlament.
Also ich bezweifele jetzt mal, dass das äh sich bei diesem Veto wirklich um einen äh.
Ich denke auch, dass es da.
Gesetz verankert des Vetohandels, sondern dass das einfach nur eine Machtausübung im Rahmen des Kabinetts war.
Ich bin tatsächlich ähm sehr äh ja genau, also aber ich bin trotzdem überrascht, dass ein Kulturstaatsminister das machen kann. Das war mir so nicht bekannt, dass er einfach sagen kann, wir streichen das mal von der Tagesordnung.
Ja, offensichtlich geht das so.
Offensichtlich geht das und man kann sich dann danach sogar noch.
Bei der CDU.
Man kann sich dann danach noch irgendwohin stellen und äh sich damit sogar noch angeben, ja. Also das ist äh wie gesagt, äh.
Starkes Stück Bernd.
Per Hand, echt.
Tja.
Dachte, ich dachte, er wäre einer von uns, aber also ich muss mal gucken. Ich.
Nicht jeder Neumann.
Ich werde das natürlich sowieso dem Hoherat des Familiennah, der Familie nochmal dieses Fehlverhalten anzeigen und dafür eine, eine öffentliche, öffentliche.
Genau, du wirst du wirst enterbt.
Der Neumannsche Familienrat distanziert sich von Bernd Neumann.
Distanziert sich von Bernd Neumann.
Ja, also unklar, wie es da weitergeht und schon ziemlich äh ziemlich interessant, wie also jemand da so stark gegen äh ziemlich klar den Verbraucherschutz dienliche,
Gesetzgebung feuern kann, möchte und tut.
Ja, gibt's da noch was zu sagen? Nee. Gut.
Als nächstes das war das war etwas Interessantes und zwar haben sich einige NGOs.
Dazu entschieden, bei der OECD Beschwerde gegen zwei Firmen einzureichen und zwar gegen Trophy und gegen Gamma,
Troicor ist, ich hatte da früher, das war interessant bei meinen Recherchen
äh schließe ich dann auf Artikel, die ich früher bei Netzpolitik orggeschrieben habe vor zwei Jahren oder so. Ähm Trophychor ist,
Eine Unternehmenssparte von Nokia Siemens Netz Networks. Ähm und Nokia Siemens Networks hat quasi die deren Überwachungssparte zweitausendsechs verkauft,
Die äh firmiert jetzt unter dem Namen äh Trovico und Nokia Siemens, Networks hat das getan, weil ähm
wird sicherlich mehrere verschiedene Überlegungen gegeben haben, aber unter anderem war es, glaube ich, auch nicht so schön, dass der wohlklingende Name Nokia Siemens äh im Zusammenhang mit äh Überwachungstechnologie in Diktaturen gebracht werden konnte,
Ähm und,
es sind es wird also jetzt durch oder es wurde durch ehemalige Nokia Siemens Manager bekannt, dass äh NSN quasi damals Beziehungen mit Bahrain hatte,
Und diese Geschäftsbeziehung äh mit dem Verkauf des Unternehmens natürlich bei Trowichor geblieben sind. Das heißt, die Überwachungstechnologie, die ähm Trovico herstellt.
Ähm ist tatsächlich in Bahein, nach nach aktuellem Wissensstand aktiv. Ähm.
Jetzt ist die Frage, was bauen die überhaupt? Ja, also ähm das sind so die die Technik, die sie anbieten. Ähm.
Muss man sich wie so ein Live Netz Netzwerkmanagement irgendwie vorstellen. Na also ähm quasi das Sammeln von,
von Kommunikationsdaten auf der beim Provider selber, ja? Also am, am MSC, am PSTN oder so, also quasi in der beim Provider selber steht dann die Profikorkiste
und kann dann äh bestimmte äh bestimmte Kunden abhören. Deshalb übliches
Verfahren für für dann vielleicht noch so. Denn dann bauen sie oben drauf, dass ihr zweiter Dienst zum Data Intelligence, wo man dann diese Kommunikationsdaten
noch zusammenführen kann mit Bewegungsdaten, Bank äh Bankdaten und ähnlichen Sachen,
Bieten da oben drauf dann noch ähm Analysetools an. Und ähm,
die also dann quasi diese Daten zusammenführen und dann da so eine Rasterfahndung ermöglichen oder auch das äh das Überwachen von Personengruppen,
Und außerdem äh für den für den äh um das für die maßgeschneiderte Überwachungslösung dann noch so Consulting und äh Customer Care Angebot. Ja, das ist also das, was was Trowichor macht.
Ähm Gamma, die andere Firma,
Ist ja bei uns ein alter Bekannter, deren äh Software Finn Fischern äh die vermutlich der auf dem kommerziellen Staatstrojanermarkt momentan auf jeden Fall das äh,
stärkste Angebot ist wurde deren,
Heißt das, heißt, glaube ich, die Myware dann selber, äh wurde auch in Barein gefunden. Ja, da wurden also Aktivisten, wurde äh wurden infizierte E-Mails zugesendet. Ähm,
Und außerdem in Ägypten, bei bei Stürmung der alten Regierung äh dann Angebote entdeckt, die
an die Regierung gemacht hat. Da ging's für um ein Angebot im Volumen von zweihundertneunzigtausend Euro für Software, Hardware und training im Umgang mit diesen,
äh Staatstrojaner. Ähm,
Das sind also die beiden Firmen gegen die jetzt äh Privacy International, Reporter ohne Grenzen, das bei Rhein Center for Human Rights ähm bei reinwatch,
und das European Center Constitutional and Human Rights, äh eine OECD Beschwerde angestrengt haben.
Was das ist.
Das ist das ist es, äh das hat mich dann auch den meisten Teil der Recherche gekostet. Was ist überhaupt die OECD?
OECD ist die Organisation für wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung,
und sie definiert in der Regel, es ist ein ein quasi vierunddreißig Länder drin und diese vierunddreißig Länder gelten so ungefähr als die sagen wir mal die entwickelten reichen Länder.
Und hauptsächlich kümmert sich die OECD äh darum,
Statistiken zu sammeln, aufzubereiten, ähm Studien zu erarbeiten, so gemeinsame Forschung irgendwie anzustrengen. Und versteht sich als ein Forum, in dem diese mächtigen Regierung, also ihre,
Erfahrungen austauschen und so best practicees äh identifizieren.
Und für gemeinsame Probleme mal so 'ne Lösung erarbeiten. Das Hauptmill, was die haben um sich durchzusetzen ist eher der Gruppenzwang, das heißt sie haben also ist keine offizielle Organisation, die wirklich irgendwie ein Mandat hat, sondern eher so was wie
der reichesten Rat oder sowas der Welt.
Na ja, es ist so einfach so ein Einigungs äh Gremium, wo man sich halt äh in irgendeiner Form ähm für eine wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit eben auf Regeln einigt und die dann mehr oder weniger umsetzt. Das heißt, da ist auch niemand so unmittelbar,
Ähm verpflichtet, jetzt wie bei EU, sondern man kann das dann so machen und ich weiß nicht, das läuft dann immer über irgendwelche Kontaktstellen, dann wird das irgendwie eingebracht. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass wenn so eine Beschwerde dann,
eingereicht wird, dass da danach äh alle Mitgliedstaaten äh vor Erschütterungen zittern,
Ja, aber es ist zumindest ein ein Weg, eine Öffentlichkeit zu finden für dieses Problem und das ist das, was jetzt hier,
gewählt wurde. Mangels anderer,
Wege, weil es ist ja sozusagen nicht im eigentlichen Sinne illegal, also es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt eine Anzeige stellen könnte auf Basis irgendeines Gesetzes, weil eben,
das alles nicht verboten ist, sondern es ist eigentlich eher so aufm moralischen äh Ebene angesiedelt und das soll, glaube ich, diese Beschwerde auch rüberbringen.
Genau dafür hat die OECD aber ihre Leitsätze
dass man bei, dass die dass die Mitgliedstaaten angehalten sind im internationalen Handel darauf zu achten, dass ihre Unternehmen Menschenrechtsstandards waren und negative Auswirkungen,
die Anwendung der Produkte versuchen, zu vermeiden oder zu vermindern. Ja und genau an diesem Punkt äh setzt er sie jetzt an und wollen quasi bei den OECD-Mitgliedsstaaten dann hoffentlich Sanktionen,
Oder eine eine Einigung auf eine Beschränkung des Exportes von solchen ähm,
angeboten, Produkten und Dienstleistungen ähm erwirken. Ähm.
Bessere Politik für ein besseres Leben lautet die.
Ja also da kann man jetzt äh.
Sich alles drunter vorstellen.
Ja, also wo, da kann man nicht nein.
Kann man ja auch nicht nein sagen. Oder also ich meine, das wollen wir doch alle.
Das wollen wir alle und die OECD wird das jetzt machen, noch kurz zur Verteidigung. Ähm Gamma äh behauptet natürlich nach wie vor, dass äh,
dass die die äh Finn, Fischer äh oder Finns bei äh Myware ihnen dabei im Zuge einer Demonstration äh gestohlen und umgebaut wurde,
ja? Ähm und sie niemals an Bareien äh verkauft hätten. Ähm.
Das sagt also, ja, sagt, sagt Gamma und Trovico hat sich, glaube ich, nicht großartig äh geäußert, ne. Also es sind schon,
Also Trophychor ist schon echt äh krasser Kram. Das waren die sind damals äh in die Medien geraten. Da war man bei Nokia Siemens sicherlich froh
dass man den Namen bereits nicht mehr äh hatte, aber trotzdem hat jeder Journalist das ausgegraben. Ähm als da rein
in bei reindiszidenten gefoltert wurden und in diesen Foltergesprächen mit,
den den Inhalten von SMS-Nachrichten konfrontiert wurden. Die sie gesendet hatten,
Ähm und ich glaube, in anderen Ländern, ich bin, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, in welchem Stadt das war, da wurden dann also auch quasi Bewegungsprofile von, also da konnte man quasi der Diktator hatte da die Möglichkeit, SMS,
Nachrichten an eine Menschenversammlung zu schicken, weil die, weil die Trobi-Cor-Software also ermöglicht, zu erkennen, wo sammeln? Beim Iran, ne.
Ich habe das so in Erinnerung.
Ich hab's auch so in Erinnerung, wollte es nur nicht sagen. Also im Iran war das so, dass.
Sag das jetzt einfach mal so.
Ja, ich bin, wenn du das bestätigst, dann bin ich mir da auch sicher. Ich hätte ja irgendwie auch drüber geschrieben da was, also da wurden quasi an die Gruppe, an die Demonstrierende Gruppe.
Da nicht hin.
Geht da nicht hin.
Euch nicht gut. Ja. Naja, das war so zu der Zeit der Proteste. Was dann also sich auch darin äußerte, dass die Leute dann keine Nukliatelfone mehr kaufen.
Da gab's äh Boykott-Aufruf zweitausendneun, ja.
Genau. Ich weiß nicht, ob das äh nennenswert äh äh also ob das sozusagen noch groß geschadet hat, betrachtet Tatsache, dass Not ja ohnehin am laufenden Meter weniger Telefone verkauft. Aber das äh habe ich auch noch so in Erinnerung.
Weil man sagen muss, also die Nuklear Siemens, eine das sind das sind dann die, die bauen quasi, die
der Laie würde sagen, die Schaltgeräte in in Netzwerken oder dann zum Beispiel die Funkmasten und solche Geschichten, ja oder die die Technologie im Prinzip dann GSM, drei G, LTE Technologie, solche Sachen.
Genau und das äh Zeug ist dann sozusagen so das Armaturenbrett für die Totalüberwachung.
Ja, das das ist dann das Teil, wofür es dann den den Port gibt, ja.
Äh aus den Geräten dann auch was zu machen, ja, statt nur äh sie nur ruhten zu lassen, wie jeder andere es erwarten würde.
Also was ist das Ziel dieser Aktion? Ähm die Reporter ohne Grenzen und die anderen Organisationen wollen also, dass
äh Gamma und Troico ihre Verträge mit Bareien und anderen autoritären Staaten offenlegen. Äh diese äh auf ihre Menschenrechtsverträglichkeit prüfen und dann äh die Lieferung und Dienstleistungen
einstellen, wenn man feststellt, dass ihre Produkte zur Verletzung von Menschenrechten genutzt werden,
dann entsprechend in Zukunft Vertragsklauseln haben, in denen so etwas verboten wird.
Altverträge nachverhandeln und sich selber dazu zu selbst dazu zu verpflichten, die Menschenrechtsverträgliche Anwendung vorab und fortlaufend,
überprüfen und eventuell sogar mit technischen Vorkehrungen einem Missbrauch der Technologien
entgegen zu wirken, das ist natürlich nicht möglich. Aber äh schön, dass das, dass man das mal vorschlägt. Ähm da war noch angemerkt, ich hatte das ja vor Kurzem gesagt, dass der äh Martin Münch, der Geschäftsführer von
Gamma,
International, dem deutschen Zweig von der Gamma Group, die außerdem auch in den ähm USA, in den in den UK ansässig ist, ähm gesagt hatte, dass er mit,
NGOs spricht, um sich quasi sein Produkt da grün zu waschen, weiß zu waschen.
Ähm er sagt, es derer gäbe es zwei und er nennt nicht ihre Namen. Ich habe aber von einer anderen Seite,
quasi direkt aus der IFF die Bestätigung, dass äh die Electronic Fontyer Foundation auf jeden Fall sich mit ihm unterhalten hat
Äh die wollen natürlich nicht irgendwie gemeinsame Sache mit ihm machen, haben sich aber offensichtlich zumindest des Dialoges nicht verwehrt, ihm einen Eindruck
von den äh Menschenrechts äh Anforderungen zu vermitteln, die sie bei so etwas sehen,
Ja, also dass das nur hatte, dass,
einer Mailing-Liste bekannt gegeben, dass sie da auch im im Kontakt standen. Ansonsten hat Martin Münch äh bekannt gegeben
dass äh er äh so eine Art äh Human Rights Rat, also so ein Menschenrechtsrat in der Firma etablieren wird und das vermutlich aus Mangel an ähm.
Bewerbern er dann da den Vorsitz haben wird? Ich meine der gründet eine Firma für Überwachungssoftware, verkauft den Schrott irgendwie nach Ägypten und Nachbar rein.
Und das dann selber der Menschenrechtsvertreter sozusagen.
Ja, er war, das ist völlig in Ordnung, weil er ist nämlich politisch neutral, wie er feststellt, ja, also.
Ach. Na das ist ja ein glückliches äh eine glückliche Fügung. Das ist eine sehr glückliche Fügung. Ja.
Er ist eine sehr glückliche Führung, die sich da äh trifft, ja. Ähm ja.
Man kann auch Glück haben. Tja. Ja. Was soll man dazu noch sagen?
Okay, also, Reporter ohne Grenzen möchte, dass da die OECD mal das Auge drauf hält und äh gelohnt hat sich die Aktion allein deshalb schon, weil es eine sehr
ausführliche Berichterstattung darüber gab was für Technologien das sind und man darf auch nicht
müde werden, zu erwähnen, dass das eben alles äh äh aus Deutschland auch kommt, ne? Also ähm,
zünden nicht unerheblichem Ausmaß äh zumindest der wichtigste, die wichtigste Person in der Firma, schon mal ein Deutscher. Wer für Gamma arbeitet, macht da in der Regel eher einen Hehl draus.
Ähm.
Ja, wir sind ja ein ein freies Land und äh hier werden die wird die Gesellschaft nicht total überwacht, aber falls sie da Bedarf haben, können wir ihnen natürlich entsprechende Technologie zur Verfügung.
Ja, wird ja, das hatten wir auch schon berichtet, das kann man im Moment natürlich mit den deutschen Behörden da äh sich unterhält und schaut, wie man denn eine Software bauen könnte, die den deutschen äh Anfordernissen dann gerecht wird.
Coming soon. Gut.
Dann gibt's noch zwei zwei kleinere Meldungen, die eher so der der Vollständigkeit halber.
Drei haben wir noch. Ich habe dann auch noch was. Oh, da ist auch. Kleinen Schmankerl.
Oh, du hast auch noch was. Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui. Das sind dann immer die, die kleinen Schranker, ja. Ähm der Kanzlerkandidat der SPD.
Wie heißt er noch gleich?
Ähm Steinmeier. Per Steinbrück. Per Steinbrück hat ähm,
hat ein Block nicht gehabt,
Wie wie war das? Es ist mir es eine nicht genannt werden wollende Unternehmerpersönlichkeiten haben einen sechsstelligen Betrag.
Auf den Tisch gelegt, damit er einen Blog kriegt, dann wurde dieses Blog aufgesetzt, dann gab's schon mal eine ganze Menge Stress, weil es natürlich mal wieder der nächste
war, ja, also ich glaube, äh die Fettnäpfcheneinheit wird turnusgemäß in diesem Jahr, glaube ich, an Herrn Steinbrück äh weitergeleitet. Es gibt ja dann sozusagen immer so ehrenhafte Namensträger, ja, äh für den Abstand zwischen zwei Fettnäpfchen, das ist jetzt ein Steinbrück
und.
Du bist die kleinste Einheit.
Ja, ja. Und ähm ja
zielsicher, mal wieder herein gestapft, vor allem auch noch mit dieser wirklich illustren Sache, so mit ja, er hätte damit ja eigentlich nichts zu tun, aber macht ihr mal, also wirklich sehr authentisches äh Projekt. Ich glaube, das hätte viel Erfolg gehabt. Also ich glaube schon die erste
Welle von Bad Press, die die das,
Qual seiner Ankündigung erzeugt hat, dürfte wahrscheinlich schon bei der SPD äh zu Schockgefrierung, Hirnbereich äh geführt haben, weil sie einfach gleich gemerkt haben, dass das sozusagen gleich der nächste Napf ist. Ähm,
und waren dann irgendwie dann doch sehr froh, dass es äh,
eine Gruppe äh äh gab von Freidrehenden äh Netzaktivisten, die dann angefangen haben, dieses,
mit äh Didos äh Attacken zu belegen, der sich die technische Administration dieses Blogs irgendwie nicht,
Nicht gewappnet äh ausreichend gewappnet äh äh gegenüber ansah.
Und dann lief das irgendwie so ein paar Tage und dann beschlossen sie, dass naja, wenn das jetzt sowieso hier nur gedehnt wird, dann dann lassen wir das halt sein.
Geht es halt nicht.
Sie haben dann irgendwie, also es gab eine großartige ähm Erklärung dann dazu, in der sie, glaube ich, davon sprachen. Wir wollten hier nur ein kleines Blog machen.
Aber ähm hier CIA äh Great äh Hackerabwehr.
Können wir nicht. Können wir hier nicht bringen. Und äh.
Können wir hier nicht bringen. Und äh geben uns daher gegenüber den, den Feind der Meinungsfreiheit äh Schlag. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ähm.
Vorausgesetzt, dass es tatsächlich ein Dedos war. Ja und nicht einfach nur, also sagen wir mal, ein ich kenne das ja selber.
System so.
Kenne das ja selber ähm,
äh eine eine Seite, die plötzlich sehr, sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt, jetzt out of the Box, dann relativ schnell auch mal die
Füße hochlegt. Da muss man sich ein bisschen Mühe geben und dafür sorgen, dass sie einen nennenswerten Besucher äh Ansturm dann auch mal überleben kann. Also ich habe, glaube ich.
Oder zumindest den Ansturm einer bestimmten Besucherart,
auch einfach sei, dass sie das Ding gleich äh äh von innen aufgehackt haben. Das weiß man halt nicht so ganz genau. Nur diese Ausrede mit wir machen jetzt das Blog nicht, nachdem wir's irgendwie, wie lange lief das? Vier, fünf Tage.
Tage. Von Samstag bis Mittwoch.
Super, ja. Also äh das, ich meine, das ist natürlich sehr sozialdemokratisch, ja, also auch für Blogs gilt jetzt wahrscheinlich die dreißig Stunden Woche,
ja, die werden dann einfach nur dreißig Stunden pro Woche äh betrieben. Das ist äh auch fair, ne?
Naja und äh ich glaube, was äh was wir also jetzt äh nicht erwähnt haben, ist, dass die Bundestagsverwaltung dann auch mal äh wegen Parteienfinanzierung da äh nachschauen wollte. Weil wenn jemand äh, wenn wenn sich irgendwie unter anonyme Unternehmer dazu bereiterklären, für für einen sechsstelligen Betrag,
Kandidaten zu pushen und dann zu schreiben. Er wollte so ja und und dann meinen, dass dann nicht
irgendwie wegen illegalen illegalen Parteifinanzierung da mal,
wird, ne? Und sich dann noch äh Steinbrück und sein Sprecher widersprechen, äh was was die Kenntnis äh derer angeht, die es machen, ne. Also wo dann Steinbrücke immer sagte,
ich weiß nicht, wer das ist und ich hab ihnen gesagt, sie können gerne über mich bloggen, so ungefähr. Was ja auch in Ordnung wäre
ja? Was ja tatsächlich auch in Ordnung wäre, wenn aber dann da Unternehmer sagen, wir stecken hier ähm nennenswert Geld rein,
und stellen irgendwie dann diese Medienagentur, die Agentur des Medienberaters Karl Heinz Steinkühler,
Und so weiter, um da professionelle Wahlkampfhilfe zu leisten, dann geht das natürlich nicht, ne? Äh insofern könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass ähm.
Das ist irgendwas haben die mit.
Das ist so die die Stones, die Stones-Verschwörung ist das.
Also ja, äh auf jeden Fall äh.
Sie nicht den Stein der Weisen gefunden, das kann man nicht sagen.
Nee, da haben sie nicht die entscheidende Weise gefunden und haben jetzt auch keinen Block mehr, ja. Also ein, ein, eine sehr amüsante Angelegenheit, wobei ich äh finde, dass diese sollte es da tatsächlich,
Dedos oder Hackerangriffe drauf gegeben haben, muss ich sagen, es wird auch nicht in Ordnung finde, weil wir hätten noch sehr viel mehr Spaß damit haben können. Ja, dass wenn das.
Ja, das muss, das muss man, glaube ich,
generell mal sagen. Ich meine, auch wenn es auch wenn sagen wir mal die Gruppe jetzt quasi indirekt da so ein bisschen die Lacher auf ihrer Seite äh äh hatte oder beziehungsweise die Lacher waren auf der anderen Seite und dadurch äh
scheint sich das irgendwie so ein bisschen zu legitimieren. Ich denke, da sind wir uns auch einig äh in Dinos, dass wir einfach solche äh Sachen eigentlich überhaupt nicht gut finden,
klar, dass das mag ganz amüsant sein, wenn einem das jetzt grad mal äh äh politisch oder auch nur privattechnisch halbwegs in den Kram passt, aber es kann nicht sein,
dass äh Gruppen, das gilt auch vor allem hier für äh so Vereinigungen wie äh Anonnemus, ja,
ist die einfach so auseinander selbstgerechten Haltung heraus, meinen da, das passt uns jetzt hier gerade mal nicht in den Kram. Wir verstehen das vielleicht zwar auch nicht so richtig, aber wir machen das jetzt einfach mal tot.
Ist es auch sah einfach plump, ne? Lasst euch was Schöneres einfallen. Ähm,
ist unsportlich, ja, gegen gegen, sage ich mal, ein schönes Diffacement oder so, hat ja keiner was, wo man dann, da wird dann einen halben Tag drüber gelacht, dann äh muss der atmen, dass die Sicherheitslücke einmal fixen oder so, ne? Und
So, da kann man ja irgendwie noch drüber reden, aber.
Ja, da kann man auch noch, da kann man auch noch sehr viel ähm,
Da hätte man sogar noch kreativer gegen vorgehen können, ja, man hätte auch noch ein per Watch Block, per Block, Watch Blog machen können, ja, per Block watch oder so was, ja? Oder sozusagen dann die dort geposteten Artikel äh gleich wieder auseinander.
Plagiate.
Ja. Welche Lobbygruppe hat denn hier geblockt.
Also man muss ehrlich sagen so, wir hatten nur fünf Tage oder Samstag, Sonntag, Montag, Dienstag, fünf Tage Spaß
an diesem Blog, bei, weil ihr den jetzt 'ne, 'ne Exit-Strategie gegeben habt, die noch dazu
ihnen ermöglicht, irgendwie wieder der Netzgemeinde äh oder Teilen der Netzgemeinde vorzuhalten, dass sie eben Feinde der Meinungsfreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit oder äh
oder so sonst was werden, ne? Oder Kriminelle, ja? Also das, ich meine, das finde ich ja auch zum Beispiel nicht, also äh Dedosangriffe sind tatsächlich
auch häufig im Kriminellen Bereich zu sehen, nämlich bei der Erpressung, ja, wo also einfach ähm,
im im wirtschaftlich auf Webseiten angewiesenen Bereichen äh Erpressung stattfinden, gesagt wird, du das Weihnachtsgeschäft, das wäre doch schade, wenn äh da dein Online-Shop nicht erreichbar wäre, solche
Dinge. Insofern sind das auch wird ist das auch was, was Kriminelle durchaus tun? Ähm.
Dass du so ein politisches Schutzgeld, ne? Sagt er immer so, ah, ihr wollt äh auch noch hier äh publizieren am Wahlkampf teilnehmen, na dann äh schicken wir euch da mal hier unseren digitalen Luigi. Und ihr wisst ja schon, äh was zu tun ist so.
Unter anderen Umständen äh wie gesagt kann man ja teilweise dafür argumentieren, dass es im Rahmen der
der Online-Demonstration dann da sage ich mal im durchaus auch 'ne Maßnahme ist die die unter Umständen dann auch mal legitim,
als legitim zu verstehen ist, in diesem Zusammenhang ist das aber ganz offensichtlich nicht der Fall.
Ja, dass also äh kein, das ist einfach eine blöde, blöde Nummer, ja? Und ich ich bin vor allem traurig, um um den schönen Spaß, den man jetzt den Leuten mit Humor, ja, die wirklich, sage ich mal, Sinn, für Humor haben, noch mit dem äh Pairblock hätten haben können, finde ich das jetzt,
schade, dass man den, den äh das so einfach gemacht hat, weil äh für die grauhaarigen Männer der SPD ist das jetzt eine völlig akzeptable Exit-Strategie, weil,
wenn da die äh wenn da die
das angreifen und so äh und man das CIA äh Abwehr braucht, äh das geht ja nun mal nicht, ne? Und da das also, ne, habt ihr keinem Gefahr.
Mit kriminellen Methoden. Seid ihr. Schämt euch.
Ja. Und jetzt haben wir dieses schöne Blott nicht mehr. Ich meine, da wäre noch, das wäre noch Hammer geworden, wäre noch echt witzig gewesen. Naja, okay. Tja. Per Block.
Das war uns woanders äh dran erheitern, ne.
Dann gibt es, gab es eine, eine kurze Anfrage von Jens Geier.
Sozialdemokrat im im Europaparlament.
Der also da mal wissen wollte, was denn so der der Internetberater.
Von gekostet hat und zwar, wir wissen ja alle, das ist ähm derjenige, der beim Doktoren äh Titelkampf, der das eins zu null für die CDU geschossen hat, ähm,
Ja, also lange her, ne.
Wie steht's jetzt grad?
Vier zu drei oder so was.
Drei. Mhm.
Fünf zu drei oder was? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau. Ist jetzt der erste Minister aus dem Kabinett Merkel, der geht musste wegen der hat damit auf den geht das alles.
Ja. Der hat einfach den Trendsetter.
Das ist der Trendsetter, ja. Ja, der bei dem bei dem das noch ähm, na ja, wie auch immer. Ihr wisst alle, die Rede ist von,
Carl Theodor Maria von uns zu. Äh haste nicht gesehen. Guten Berg. Ähm und der hat äh der macht das ja ehrenamtlich für die äh,
für die EU und jetzt wollte der Jens Geier,
mal wissen, wie sieht das denn aus, äh was hat er denn so bis jetzt gemacht oder was hat er denn gekostet bisher, ne, also wurde ihm gesagt, ja äh ist jetzt so ähm.
Könnte man ihm natürlich nicht wirklich sagen, was äh was er äh,
wofür man ihn bezahlt hat und so, weil er sensible Diskussionen mit äh,
Mit Personen, äh die selber in hohem persönlichen Risiko stehen äh geführt hat und jetzt irgendwelche Details seiner Aktivitäten dazu publizieren könnte. Natürlich diese Person in Gefahr bringen.
Ah, ist geheim.
Naja, stimmt, also wenn sich in Deutschland jemand mit Gutenberg trifft.
Wenn das rauskommt.
Geil. Ist das durchaus politische Gefahr, in die er sich.
Ja, er hat sich äh hat sich mit der CSU getroffen, aber psst.
Ähm ja und äh aber immerhin, er hätte äh,
mit wichtigen Personen, vor allem der EU und den USA äh persönliche Beziehungen hergestellt. Na ja klar, das ist ja dankebar. Danke, dass er das gemacht hat, das wollte er ohnehin. Ähm immerhin ähm,
neunzehntausendachthundertzweiundsechzig Euro und ein Cent Reisekosten und Spesen in dem knapp einen Jahr oder etwas über ein Jahr, dass er das,
Jetzt mach, da muss man sagen, das ist nicht besonders viel für Reisekosten.
War wahrscheinlich einfach ein Flug.
Da kommt halt drauf an, wie viele Reisen er gemacht hat.
Ja
Also ähm.
Ja, da fliegt man einmal First class.
Nach Asien und zurück? Oder? Also,
eigentlich drin gewesen sein. Wir wissen es nicht, äh kann man auch keinen äh Strick draus drehen. Ich habe eh keine Ahnung, was äh in dem Mann mittlerweile vorgeht. Vielleicht äh
bewegt sich da ja nochmal irgendwas. Er hat auf jeden Fall hart einstecken müssen. Das muss man äh auch mal erkennen. So.
Gibt's jetzt keinen weiteren Aspekt noch nachzuliefern, oder?
Nein, das ich denke, das muss einfach nur mal so.
Man muss einfach mal äh gesagt werden, genau. Was auch noch äh äh gesagt werden sollte, so zum Abschluss noch ein kleiner Filmtipp. Äh es ist ein Film herausgekommen, eine Dokumentation zu. Ähm.
Hast du das schon als Tor und runtergeklemmt?
Ja. Darf man nämlich mit? Nee, logisch.
Darf man nämlich, ne? Geil, ladet das alle per Tore drunter.
Ist auch auf YouTube. So ist es nicht. Also ist natürlich frei verfügbar. Äh von, wie heißt der, Simon Klose treffe ich's gerade richtig? Ähm Dokumentarfilm, der hat so die äh drei,
Ähm Gründer beziehungsweise Sprecherpersonen von The Pirat Bay äh über die Dauer dieses Prozesses, der in Schweden äh lief ähm begleitet,
und dabei auch ganz gut eingefangen. Die Absurdität äh mit der diese Verhandlung ähm gelaufen ist. Das würde ich ein interessantes äh Bild, auch ein interessantes,
Hm, interessante, wie soll ich sagen, Vorstellung der Persönlichkeiten, die dahinter äh stehen und dieser Mangel an Organisationen und auch äh,
kriminelle Energie, ja, also äh das wird da ganz gut deutlich und jedem, der vielleicht schon mal mit dieser Webseite äh Kontakt hatte, würde ich doch mal raten,
sich diesen Film anzuschauen, das ist auch kein Schmerz, weil es nämlich ein wirklich ein wirklich sehr schön,
Film ist. Also ich finde die Bilder und die Atmosphäre ähm den Schnitt und alles finde ich sehr gelungen.
Und heißt AFK. Was warum?
Ähm ich weiß es, ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe den Film gestern Nacht beim Hören von
habe ich dann den Download angestoßen und wir sind gestern nicht mehr dazu gekommen uns den noch anzuschauen, aber ich weiß warum, möchtest du es erzählen oder soll ich es von Hörensagen erzählen?
Es es gibt in dem Film eine Szene, in der Peter Sunde, der große Peter Sonde, der, das ist wirklich der große. Er ist ja auch.
Ist definitiv, er ist er ist groß und er ist äh ich finde ihn auch wirklich einen der beeindruckendsten Persönlichkeiten in diesem ganzen Netz äh Geflecht.
Man kann nicht oft genug betonen, wie wie unglaublich wichtig und toll,
ähm Peter Sohne ist, der äh gefragt wurde,
Äh wann er jemanden zum ersten Mal IRL getroffen hätte für die IRL in Real Life, eine klassische Abkürzung aus dem.
Genau, also hier äh ich habe hier sogar den den den Ausschnitt, wie äh der Dialog gelaufen ist. Äh und er antwortet no we down usty expression.
Also IRL, we say, äh elf K,
A F K, Entschuldigung, ich bin hier in tausend verschiedenen äh Sprechweisen äh gefangen. Bei Sätzen, also,
Fragt ein anderer und wird so erklärt und Peter meint dann,
Und das finde ich eine.
Hammer, ja.
Ein wirklich ein ganz großes äh Statement über die Lustigkeit des Moments äh hinaus, weil das eben auch glaube ich ganz gut treibt, was,
Ganz gut dokumentiert, was was diese Gruppe äh treibt, was insbesondere äh Peter Sunde treibt, ja? Also der
für meinen Geschmack wirklich ein sehr realistisches Verhältnis äh hat auch zu diesen Dingen, der also nicht so,
abgehoben daherkommt, sondern wirklich sehr klar äh argumentiert und meiner Meinung nach dann extrem zukunftskompatible Grundeinstellung auch an den Tag legt und die auch
in deinem ganzen Verhalten gut dokumentiert, ja? Und jetzt aber auch nicht nur so lunimäßig äh daher äh rennt, sondern ja auch ganz konkrete Maßnahmen ergreift, nicht zuletzt
äh Flatter, ja. Was ja sein äh Brainchiled ist.
Aber ich finde das sehr schön äh einfach auch mal klar zu sagen, ja Internet ist einfach, Internet ist für Real,
Ja und äh wenn kein Internet, dann heißt es nur, dass ich mich von der Tastatur entfernt habe.
Eine andere schöne Stelle, wo dieser Gottfried irgendwie völlig nervös zitternd rumsitzt, weil er irgendwie schon seit ein paar Stunden keinen Kontakt mehr mit dem Internet hatte und so ein bisschen auf Entzug war. Also, schaut euch den Film an, ist wirklich toll.
Wie lange geht der ungefähr?
Ähm hat so die typische Laufzeit anderthalb Stunden, glaube ich. Weiß jetzt nicht genau.
Okay? Also ich habe jetzt hier äh ja äh runterladen und bei der Gelegenheit denke ich auch, sollte man auf jeden Fall ähm,
den dann auch den vollen Genuss sich geben, den mal äh als,
herunterzuladen und auch mal schön zu sieden, ohne dass man jetzt noch den Schutz eines VPN-Anbieters der engeren Wahl äh davor schaltet, weil das ist also etwas, was man,
frei da so schön tauschen kann und bisher auch heute,
selten, ja? Und auch für diejenigen, die vielleicht die die schöne Tradition des Torens Seedens nicht mehr so pflegen, wie das vielleicht andere tun, sollten hier durchaus nochmal darüber nachdenken, den Bitcoin Clint ihrer Wahl herunterzuladen,
und des des da mal in vollem Ausmaße zu fröhen.
Genau. Wer den hier nicht sieht, wird abgemahnt.
Genau, von uns. Ich, ja, ich ich kann das, ist kein Problem. Ich ich monitore jetzt einfach mal den Swarm da. Ja, also gucken wir mal. Wir mahnen ab.
Alles klar.
Wenn eure IP-Adresse wer bei uns kommentieren will, dann gleiche ich das ab, ob die IP-Adresse gleichzeitig den den Toren sieht und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann.
Genau, wir haben hier nämlich hier unsere neue Konsole von Trowicore installiert und wir sehen alles,
Gut Schluss äh mit schlechten Witzen. Äh.
Sehr viele schlechte Witze gemacht, Tim.
Ja, ja, das wurde ja auch mal Zeit, aber sonst immer so. Vorne weit vorne liegen, genau.
Hochklassige Witze. Ja.
Genau, so sieht's aus. Und nächste Woche machen wir weiter oder äh die Nuss.
Hm ja, gehe ich von aus.
Programm, ja? Ist klar. Dann bleibt uns nicht mehr viel äh zu sagen. Gibt's noch Termine irgendwas, äh spannendes, passiert irgendwas?
Ich achte da habe ich jetzt im Moment nix vorbereitet zu.
Nee, ich auch nicht. Also ist wahrscheinlich nichts Wichtiges. Dann seid ihr jetzt seid ihr jetzt wieder frei.
Bye-bye.